And so, if you charge a similar amount
as a startup, and it sort of resembles
the way the other vendors charge, the
customer like, "Oh, that makes sense.
It'll fit right in." Yeah. Versus when
you're a founder and you try to price it
in a totally weird way,
it'd be like if you were
if you were like a hotel and you're
like, "Oh,
you pay with seashells." You know, like,
"We don't take money here."
>> This is Dalton plus Michael. Today,
we're going to talk about how do
startups get big deals? Six-figure
deals, seven-figure deals, eight-figure
deals. How do they get big deals?
And the kind of subtitle here is, are
you selling tools or are you selling
outcomes? I think a very common
>> first office hour topic for companies
that get accepted into YC is some
version of them saying, "Dalton,
how do I get big deal?"
It's like
Like they they they haven't even Googled
it, right? This is just like a
And I think the context is that most
people
understand self-service because they've
signed up. Like, who hasn't signed up
for GitHub or signed up for Figma or,
you know, we're all used to signing up
for SaaS, putting in our credit card,
and paying for stuff. And so, I don't
think you need that much direction as a
founder on how to create
>> How to create $10 a month.
>> Yeah, like, okay, you go set up a Stripe
account and then, you know, it's it's
pretty straightforward.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's most people have not purchased
six- or seven-figure software.
>> Yeah, some of them have.
>> No, but most people have it. And so,
it's a complete black box, right?
>> It's also, I think, scary
as a result. I've never seen it happen.
I mean, I know it actually happens, but
I've never seen it, so am I going to go
do it?
>> Yep.
>> Can I Can I do it?
And I think that this is what's tricky
because,
you know, if we get to the TLDR,
how many massively successful
software companies never have to figure
this out?
I think almost everyone. And it's funny
cuz even if you're a consumer company,
right? Like Facebook has eight-figure
advertising deal. Like you know, it's
like it is really, really, really hard
to make billions of billions and
billions of dollars $10 at a time. It is
very, very hard.
And so
I often think that one of the biggest
challenges founders have is when they're
transitioning from the
>> $10 a month self-signup to
how do we figure out how to sell
big deals.
>> Usually the way I try to set this up
from people that are just like ice cold
on the topic around pricing or deal size
is I ask them to think about how they
purchase most products, which is to look
at like three to five options. Say it's
stuff on a grocery shelf. Or say you're
looking at hotel rooms. You're like,
"Oh, I need to go to New York. I need a
hotel."
>> Yep.
>> So you like go to the site
>> and they'll be like, you know, three to
five options, say
they have different prices, they have
different features. But you're sort of
choosing between those small number
options and they're all, you know, yes,
relatively similar.
>> This is how most people buy expensive
software.
>> Yes.
>> Is that they're like, "Cool. I know how
much this vendor costs and this vendor
costs and this vendor costs." And so if
you charge
a similar amount as a startup and it
sort of resembles the way the other
vendors charge the customer is like,
"Oh, that makes sense. Cool. It's a It's
200K a year. Oh, that
>> Yeah.
>> It'll It'll fit right in."
>> Versus when you're a founder and you try
to price it in a totally weird way
it'd be like if you were
if you were like a hotel and you're
like, "Oh,
you pay with seashells, you know? Like
we don't take money here."
>> You take a bath that costs this much. If
you only sleep on this half of the bed.
>> Like you're not going to make a sale,
okay? Like because you didn't take the
time to understand how the customer is
purchasing all this other software.
>> Even if those things represent your
costs. Right? So you can have this fake
first principles like, well, I'll just
charge as a function of my costs. Let me
transparently show my costs off. And
it's like, what are you doing?
>> I mean, that's fair. Yeah.
>> And so, I can't stress this enough.
Understand how other vendors that your
potential customer pay for or would
evaluate. Understand how they position
and price and sell and and just be like
that.
>> Yeah, just just make it so if they look
at you side by side with the other
vendors, you don't break their brain.
>> Yes.
>> Well, and and that's often how you get
to
make a big contract being a 20-person
company going up against a 1,000-person
company cuz it's like
the customer's buying the same thing and
you're priced the way that and you can
deliver the service. Cool. You get to
make more money.
I think another thing that happens that
I find frustrating as a business guy. I
will put my business guy hat on.
I think developers like to sell
developers. And I think developers like
to build tools and sell those tools
developers who like to buy tools.
>> Yes.
>> And I think that like
that is the easiest construction of the
world, so I'm going to believe the world
is constructed that way. I think that
corporate CEOs need to deliver revenue.
So, I think there's like a massive
disconnect, right? The CEO's
incentivized by their stock compensation
to deliver revenue and increase the
stock price of the company.
The developer wants to deliver tools and
give those tools to developer.
How do those tools translate into more
revenue for the company?
And I think there's two philosophies.
Philosophy one is that's the company's
problem.
Good luck. And philosophy two is
that's the vendor's problem.
I need to help.
I think that when you're philosophy two,
you get to charge a lot of money.
>> Yep.
>> I've heard some incredible stories about
Palantir. We have so many founders who
used to be like Palantir engineers. And
like the economics of some of these
deals, it's like we send 10 guys in to
fix your thing and you pay us a billion
dollars over 4 years because fixing that
thing made you 10 billion dollars and
nobody cares how many guys it took.
Like, I don't care if I get to make 10
billion, I'm happy to pay you one.
But, if you're like, here's a tool, go
figure it out, and the engineers of that
company can't figure it out, so that
company loses value.
>> Yep.
>> You can't ask for a lot of money.
So, this is so confusing. Why is this so
confusing?
>> I think that the engineer mindset
is to care how something works under the
hood.
>> Yes.
>> And the non-engineer mindset is that you
could care less
how it works under the hood. If
anything,
don't tell me. You're like, I don't want
to know how this works. But, they really
care a lot about whether their outcome
is achieved as quickly as possible.
>> Yes.
>> If you're waiting for someone to perform
a service for you and they're late and
they want to give you a really long,
complicated story about how there was
traffic or you know, like, just like do
the thing. Like, I don't care. Like,
>> You don't want the details.
>> And so, think about the way cameras used
to be marketed versus the iPhone. Where
it's like, megapixels and like all the
Japanese companies, oh, there's a new
camera with this and that.
>> Shutter speed.
>> Yeah. Or like the way Macs were marketed
versus PCs.
>> Specs.
>> Specs, specs, specs. And so, I just
think it's different to sell a product
to a solution-oriented customer versus
someone that really, really, really
needs to know or wants to know how it
works.
>> Yes. Just a different thing.
>> I like your vendor argument, which is
like,
I'm not going to say that tools don't
make money. There are a lot of tools
that make money. I will say, if you're
in a market where most of the vendors
are selling outcomes and you're selling
tools,
>> Yep.
>> that's probably a recipe for disaster.
Um, the other thing that I will say is I
think there are a lot of companies that
founders think are selling tools and
they're not.
Right? The number of times I've talked
to a YC founder and they'll say, look,
AWS is tools, um, Stripe is tools.
And it's like, it's so much Like unpack
that because
when AWS is selling you as a as a
startup developer
I mean, this might be semantics, but
here's what I would ask yourself.
Do these companies have large sales
teams? Are these sales people
compensated on size of contract?
And do they have like commissions and do
they have like quota? Do their largest
customers pay them tens of millions of
dollars a year if not more?
And so all these companies would fit
that bar. Well, and if those sales
people are not talking to you,
that probably means that your experience
of that product is not a representative
experience.
>> That is correct. Like signing up for
Stripe
for your self-service side project is
different than being a very large and
successful company that processes
billions of dollars and is trying to
figure out should we switch off of Chase
Merchant Services and strip off to
Stripe with our $3 billion worth of
volume.
And I think that what gets people
confused sometimes is that the brand of
a story can often be built during the
first couple years when they might only
be selling tools and they might only be
selling those tools to startups.
And the number of people I talked to who
are just like, well, obviously Stripe is
just a
Now more startups exist and more
startups use them and I'm like,
that's lazy thinking.
>> I think this brings up a related topic.
I know that um
some of the Sequoia folks put out like a
bunch of content about selling outcomes
versus selling software and to quickly
introduce my understanding of the
argument, it's the following. The AI
models make the value of code
zero. Anyone can crank out code.
And if you're trying to sell software,
every time a smarter model comes out,
the value of your code goes down.
>> Tools are getting cheaper and cheaper.
>> But if you're providing services, if
you're selling outcomes,
and you're using the AI tools internally
to produce the outcome, every time the
models get smarter, your margins get
better.
So you're like, oh yeah, we can deliver,
you know, what do you You want a
widget?" here? Oh, we can We have
widgets galore. And every time a smaller
model comes out, it's cheaper for you to
make widgets. Yes.
You're You're pumped.
>> That's only if positive feedback loops.
>> I'm not sure that's the right framework
for literally every startup. I think
that's a stretch, but I think it's an
interesting way to think about the
difference between high-value outcomes
sales versus selling SaaS.
>> So, I want to give you a challenge here.
So, I think this is a question that that
can scare people. As I'm moving from
selling tools to selling outcomes,
you know, I'm imagining a world where I
have thousands and thousands of
customers.
How can I understand each of their
businesses well enough
to be able to promise them an outcome?
That seems scary.
How would you unpack that kind of
question?
>> Well, I would start with how
the comparables or competitors in your
space
think about this. And I would ask the
customer,
"How do you evaluate outcome?" You know,
this is
This is like the classic phone a friend
if someone asks,
you know, you just ask the customer.
Yes. So, be like, "Cool, how are you
guys evaluating outcomes? And what does
success look like? And what does not
success look like?" And I'd basically
get your customers to educate you on
this one.
>> Embedded in a lot of startup founders'
minds
is a volume of important customers that
I wonder whether that's actually true.
I'll pick on a company like Snowflake.
Like,
how many customers pay Snowflake over 50
million dollars a year?
I don't know. I don't know, but I don't
think it's thousands.
And so, I think that basically one, I
think it's a simpler problem than it
looks because not all customers are
actually unique snowflakes.
>> Yep.
>> Um and probably things that work for one
company industry would work for another
company industry. But I also think two,
your biggest customers can get really
big. Like, I've got a company that I
funded, and they do logistics
coordination for commerce. And it's
like, you know what? You know how many
Walmarts there are?
There just aren't that many. So, like
the reality is is that most of their
customers
um are going to be big. And there aren't
that many big customers. So, I think
that's another way that you can kind of
unpack it where it's like you probably
don't have to solve this problem for a
thousand.
I think the second way that I would
unpack it is
you might have more intel than they do.
Because you get to operate horizontally
across a lot of your customers. You get
to see how they're using your products
to make money. You get to see the other
things they're doing to get money.
You might have a better view on what's
going on
than they do. What's funny is like you
might not need to be an expert in their
company. You might need to be an expert
in how people are using your product to
make money.
And then you can communicate that to
your other customers.
>> Is there an example of like an
outcomes-based company that you like to
reference in office hours?
>> Well, Palantir is like the the the
obvious one.
>> I think the problem with Palantir
is it so secretive that no one really
know We shouldn't explain this video.
But, uh
>> Well, what's funny is like all you have
to do is talk to people who work at
Palantir about their individual
products. Like not what Palantir does,
but just like tell me about one of your
projects. And then immediately they're
like
>> Okay.
>> Oh, like this general used this to kill
these people over here and it worked
really well. Oh, okay. Like And so to
me, they're an obvious clear example. I
think the second one that I end up
hearing about a lot is whenever you talk
to sales people for the hyperscalers.
>> Hm.
>> When the hyperscalers are selling other
big companies, often non-software
companies,
it's a completely different
conversation.
>> It's not like paper API call.
>> No. No. No. It's a completely And it's
all these like services they're going to
provide. And like, oh, like you do this
thing and we'll package our little thing
here. We'll package our here. And like
we're going to develop what to you looks
like a nice custom solution, but to us
is just picking up pieces.
>> I think Workday tried to do this.
>> Yep.
>> Right? It's like, "Oh, what is what's
your HR process? Our entire thing's
flexible. It can change as you grow, as
you do do do." So, to me, there are so
many examples, and what's frustrating to
me is it's too easy to copy the tactics
that make people
$10 million,
but that never make them a billion.
>> I think that's the thing. It's like the
number of founders I talked to where
it's like, "Well, this company made $10
billion, and they raised a Series B. If
I just do what they do, then we'll win."
>> Yeah, you know, I think my advice in
office hours about this, if I'm just
reflecting over the years, was I would
always advise early-stage companies to
try to sell upmarket.
>> Mhm.
>> Cuz it usually wouldn't work.
But if you try every few months
constantly,
>> Yeah.
>> every time you get a little bit closer
to landing the big customer.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, if I'm just reflecting on
companies that I've worked with that
ended up closing seven-figure contracts,
>> Yeah.
>> it's not that they showed up one day and
they just got it the first time they
tried. It's that they kept trying to
sell a seven-figure contract.
>> Yeah.
>> They got a no.
They understood why.
>> Yeah.
>> And then they changed something about
their product or process, and they tried
again. It's usually it'll take like a
year or two to to to get to that stage,
but if they wouldn't have been hitting
their head against the wall trying it a
bunch of times, there's 0% chance they
would have figured it out.
>> Zero. Well, and you bring up another
thing that I think generates so much
fear. Dalton, you told me I have to grow
7% week-over-week. And now you're
telling me it's going to take a year to
figure out if I close this deal. What?
You're You're setting me up to fail. I
should just sell startups to
software
>> Why are you trying to trick me?
>> Yes.
>> I can sell software to the
>> Have you guys never a
Why didn't you tell me this was going to
be so hard?
Look.
There's a lot of effort that you have to
put into things that may not work. Yes,
but you learn. Yes, and
it's kind of just part of the sales
cycle. And so, you have to do both. Hit
the growth goal and try to build and
sell things that won't be successful the
first time.
>> That's the game.
>> It's the game.
>> And I the way that I communicate to
founders on this point is
in some ways the sales cycle being slow
is a gift because you can operate a lot
of these in parallel.
>> Oh, yeah. That person you're
>> talk to, they're going to take a 2-week
vacation. They like
I think that like what founders often
get frustrated by is like the mental
load of keeping a big customer in their
head
causes them to be afraid of talking to
many of them.
>> Yep.
>> But the reality is the time
isn't that sitting you know, if you got
2-week gaps between meetings you can
>> You got you can put more on your
calendar. No, that's a great point. I'll
sometimes be like, oh, let's pull up
your calendar. Let's see what you know.
And sometimes I look at them like, oh, I
don't have any ideas, but sometimes
there's a lot of blank spot on the
calendar.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes, and I think that
if I can get founders to think, oh,
I'm hedging. All these deals aren't
going to work. Let's talk to 10 of them.
And we're learning. We can compare
notes.
Once we're talking to 10 of them, if two
of them are you know what we
can do?
>> Stop talking to them.
>> If we're only talking to one and they're
it's like,
oh, you got to slug through. And so, um
but what's tricky is like if you know
this is where we're going to end up.
I don't even want to tell you how to get
there. Just don't lie to yourself.
>> You're going to have to get here at some
point.
>> And and don't tell yourself this fake
story that like, oh, Stripe just sells
software to startups.
That's verified for false.
>> go ask ChatGPT who are sales teams and
how big are the sales teams now, right?
You can research this.
>> It's so funny. I remember having a
meeting with Andy Jassy. It must have
been like 2018.
And he was like, all right, Microsoft's
finally in the game. This year AWS has
to hire
5,000 sales people.
And first of all,
little old me, you know, like I was
like,
how do you hire 5,000 anything? You just
casually And then he's like, I forgot
the number. He's like, Microsoft has
like 120,000
sales He just said some number. I went
from being like, that's the most
impressive thing I've ever heard to, oh
my god, you have to fight those guys.
There's a hint There's a deep hint in
there.
And you know,
Microsoft got to the party 10 years
later.
>> Yep.
>> And that was
just in time. So,
if you have them up here,
don't be afraid.
Good shot.
>> Sounds good. All right, thanks, Michael.